a longtime survivor of an earlier
epidemic passed away this week Larry
Kramer the country's best known AIDS
activist died of pneumonia at age 84 in
1987 Kramer founded act up a militant
group that tried to focus the nation's
attention on HIV and AIDS around the
same time another organization formed to
bring hot meals to homebound New Yorkers
afflicted with the disease God's love we
deliver is still hard at work today now
with a client list expanded by the
coronavirus Anthony Mason visited with
them last year and returned this week
for an update logistically this is a
massive job it is Karen Perl is the CEO
of God's love we deliver the New York
charity that for nearly 35 years has
been cooking and home delivering free
meals to people too sick to shop or cook
for themselves no one should be sick and
hungry how many meals come out of here
every day out of here every day is 7200
years last year she gave me a tour of
the kitchens where they prepare and
package all their meals so how many
chefs does it take to make this kitchen
run right we have just under 20
[Applause]
at that time an army of some 14,000
volunteers put the meals together and
got them out to the people in need but
then the pandemic hit how are you
getting through this so God's love we
deliver has basically changed everything
we do first thousands of the volunteers
they relied on could no longer come at
the same time they had a surge in new
clients how quickly did you see the
demand rise overnight literally
overnight what were you thinking at that
moment when all of a sudden all these
people were calling and you were losing
volunteers my first thought was we will
figure this out because that's what
God's love we deliver does we figure it
out my second thought was oh no what
they have figured it out by simplifying
the menu so meals can be made and
packaged with fewer workers they
restructured the production line spacing
out volunteers everything is social
distance everything we have done and
every part of our business has had to
switch especially deliveries volunteers
now call in advance and leave meals at
the door we're doing far more than we
used to do but at the same time we're
doing it with fewer people remember
before the pandemic God's love was
making 7,200 meals a day and now almost
10,000 meals a day we're really knocking
it out but God's love we deliver
literally was born for this born during
the AIDS crisis in 1986 our very
founding wasn't another pandemic it was
the HIV pandemic and I think it is that
call that everybody is rising to and
doing the very best they can to meet the
increased
and the more restricted ways of working
right this is essentially your mission
this is our mission this is our moment
and God's love is delivering yet again
Anthony Mason for CBS this morning
Saturday New York so in the middle of a
pandemic they have increased the number
of meals they're providing and increase
the amount of help they're giving
Michelle pretty incredible you see that
over and over again the humanity we find
in all of this is incredible I just love
it